all right guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich for us us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
polina ibailova marinova pompliano who
is wearing her athletic
gear legally i'll just be pip uh planet
evil over marinova pompano p-i-m-p
what's up don't forget that blockfi is
now a sponsor of lunch money you can
earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account go
sign up for one right now
go to blockfy.com pomp
and you can get that interest bearing
account you literally wire your money in
they turn it into digital dollars and
you can earn up to eight point six
percent compared to the
point zero two or point zero three that
you're currently getting
in your checking account go check it out
block five dot com slash lunch money
are block five dot com slash pomp i'm an
investor i said on the board of
directors i'm a user i'm happy
and you will be too i'm happy
i'm in a great view today all right
what's going on okay so the stock market
is in an absolute raging mania
fueled by the federal reserve says long
time hedge fund manager stanley
druckenmiller he said everybody loves a
party but inevitably after a big party
there's a hangover right now we're in an
absolute raging mania
we've got commentators encouraging
companies to do stock splits
companies then go up 50 30 40
on stock splits that brings no value but
the stocks go up
that's true this is what happens when
the retail
investors are involved i feel like the
hangover's gonna be bad
maybe look here's the crazy part is uh
we've just never seen a central bank
print this much money
uh in a global pandemic let alone we've
never seen a print that much money ever
but then also you lay into it with all
the kind of economic carnage that's
happening
uh nobody knows what's gonna happen
that's that's the beauty of all this is
everyone is speculating and that's what
makes a market some people think stocks
are gonna go up
for longer some people think stocks are
gonna go down some people think that
stocks are gonna go
sideways right you just nobody knows for
sure
and everyone is literally wagering are
they speculating
of course look the stock and just to be
clear the stock market is just a casino
that's legal and that's all it really is
people are literally betting money
on what's going to happen in the future
and that's fine
and they all have kind of different ways
of valuing assets and price and all this
kind of stuff
but at the end of the day it's the
market is the referee the market will
determine who's right and who's wrong
uh stanley drunken miller i think is not
wrong in saying
there's been a party i mean since march
lows the stock market is up over fifty
percent
and remind me a stock split doesn't add
value it's literally
just the company trying to prop up it's
they're they're issuing more stock
uh kind of so for those that don't know
what a stock split is literally if you
own one share
of company a and they just say okay for
every one share you have now you have
five
right nothing changed with the company
they just created five
shares now what does happen right and i
think where sometimes it's
miscellaneously doesn't create any value
is
sometimes people do it simply to get the
price of the stock
to be lowered so let's say that you had
a stock it was worth a thousand dollars
right
well only people who have a thousand
dollars can buy that stock so if you do
a
five to one stock split meaning that uh
for every one stock you own now you own
five
well now the price is 200 and so it
appears to be cheaper
right so i i don't buy the argument that
it doesn't change anything
it doesn't change any underlying
fundamentals of the company the value
all that kind of stuff
but there is definitely a psychological
impact to it
and that's why companies are doing it
right if it didn't change anything why
would companies do it
all right so that's what's going on in
the world of luxury
lvmh says the threat of u.s tariffs on
french products has forced its
it has forced it to scrap its planned
acquisition of
tiffany which would have been the
biggest luxury goods deal in history
so lvmh is a french conglomerate said
that as things stand it would not be
able to complete the 16.2 billion dollar
deal which was announced last november
because of a succession of events which
undermined the acquisition that was a
really big deal when that was announced
yeah i don't uh i mean look obviously
coronavirus
covid19 the government lockdowns all
this kind of stuff has created a lot of
uncertainty but what what exactly are
they saying
the u.s said in july it would impose
tariffs of 25
on french products including makeup and
handbags as part of a dispute over
taxing digital companies
do you remember this with wine isn't
this kind of similar similar yeah
yeah i mean look the united states
definitely has levy uh tariffs all
around the world but
uh france specifically both in wine
luxury goods it's kind of all french
products
got hit with a big one 25 that's a lot
of course
and it's already expensive like yeah
well and what's crazy about this is
uh in some weird way the united states
has like stopped this acquisition in its
tracks
yes of course uh but i don't think that
was their intention with the tariffs
obviously
um it was just kind of this is a uh uh
ancillary damage if you will well
there's always
pretty big but still uh and the other
piece that i think is really interesting
on this
um is that the tariffs even though that
they were put in place back in july
they're not actually going to start
getting collected until january of next
year
uh so there's kind of like a six-month
period give or take
um where people know it's coming but it
isn't actually getting taken
and so it gives people some time to
start making some decisions obviously
this being one of the decisions that is
being made is hey now we're not going to
do this acquisition
i just kind of feel like we're all just
playing a giant
game of monopoly like the man isn't
gonna collect the tariff
until you pass go um
the other part that i think is
interesting
i only got eight and a half hours today
okay the other the other thing that i do
think is very interesting though
is uh you know who i feel bad for is all
of the
like 22 to 25 year old investment banker
kids who
were like sleeping under their desks or
working their asses off
on this deal and now it's not going to
happen well i don't know if i'm that
worried about those people but
yeah i mean good job i just feel bad for
them they worked really hard
you don't feel bad about the 32 year old
who can't get her luxury back from
okay what's going on at jp morgan jp
morgan chase is investigating the role
its employees may have played in
potential abuse of the ppp loans and
other pandemic relief programs
in a memo to the staff on tuesday jp
morgan urged employees to be vigilant
about fraud involving government
stimulus
programs does that mean they got it even
though they're making more money than
necessary
no i think i think what ends up
happening here is it's not
something that jp morgan did i think
what they're saying is that government
[Music]
will the govern so the way that the
government stimulus program worked this
government basically said there's no we
can hand out all this money so what they
did is they went to all these banks and
said hey you guys have the
infrastructure in place to process these
loan applications
so what we'll do is we'll work with you
you have your customers or people come
to you you
apply for pvp and then jp morgan says
like thumbs up thumbs down you know you
get you don't
and that's where they're basically
saying is that some employees may have
done
uh things that they don't agree with um
federal authorities have unsealed
charges against individuals who
allegedly abused ppp loans in the last
few months
last month the justice department
accused nearly a dozen people
participating in
scale and organized efforts to misuse
the pvp funds
remember there's trillions of dollars
sloshing around in the market and jp
morgan alone has funded more than 280
000 ppp loans totaling more than 32
billion
yeah and so obviously uh any time that
there is
market chaos there's uncertainty there's
lots of money flowing around fraud's
going to go up
uh what you hope is that uh it's not at
large institutions where uh they're
being seen as kind of the referees of
who gets the loans and who doesn't
right that's the like really sad stuff
where you expect it to happen
is uh the small business owner who uh
doesn't
want to do something fraudulent but gets
in a bad situation
fudges the number oh i'll make it up
next month and then like kind of spirals
out of control
again it's wrong but at least there you
can see
okay this person is trying to protect
their livelihood trying to
whatever and like it's not inexcusable
but at least it's
understandable yeah yeah right and so
they still should get in trouble and all
that kind of stuff
but instead if it's just at the bank and
they're just
doing things to line their pockets uh
because there's the opportunity to do it
a little bit harder to uh to kind of say
you know hey that's understandable right
i think that's just pretty unethical it
sounds like they're trying to get ahead
of that
you're gonna love this story founders
fund the venture firm started by peter
thiel led a 20 million dollar investment
in virtual
kitchen the virtual kitchen startup
helps restaurants deliver to customers
while reducing real estate costs
and this company is literally called
virtual kitchen
it's competing with travis kalanick's
cloud kitchens
virtual kitchens cloud kitchens whatever
whatever virtual kitchen was actually
founded by 2x uber executives
is that interesting does it say it
provides technology to set up commercial
kitchens designed for delivery allowing
restaurants to get food to customers
without the expense and hassle
of running a dining room or storefront
so a traditional virtual kitchen
yeah so one was a previously a product
manager for uber's marketplace business
and the other was a group manager at
ubereats they obviously have a lot of
experience
uh i actually think that they're going
up against their former boss
yeah and look travis is uh
not somebody you want to compete with
obviously but uh i also think he
understands like
there's going to be multiple winners in
the space yeah right um one thing that
that is really interesting to me
is uber has not yet been labeled as a
kind of a factory of entrepreneurs
but uh the way that they hired for those
product manager roles or their general
manager roles
um it tends to lean towards uh a lot of
these people are gonna end up leaving
uber
and starting companies of course and so
you kind of saw that with like facebook
and google or you definitely saw
facebook and google
but there's a lot of other companies
where you didn't necessarily see it
right and so uber is one of these
uh factories and interviews hasn't
really produced
a ton that i know um yeah but again it's
a different type of company i definitely
think that there are some entrepreneurs
i know of entrepreneurs have come out of
uh
airbnb um and started companies it's
just a different type of person is
attracted to work at an airbnb versus an
uber
right and so it'll be interesting to
kind of see how this picture that's cool
restaurants that partner with virtual
kitchen or cloud kitchens can still use
delivery apps like ubereats doordash and
grubhub
they just come from a virtual kitchen
versus something with a storefront
like a traditional restaurant makes
sense sometimes sometimes when i'm on
seamless i try to guess what
a virtual kitchen is because like
they'll be they'll have like a very slim
menu and like
no pictures okay um
all right the forbes 400 came out today
the forbes 400 tracks america's richest
people who are worth
a record 3.2 trillion all right don't
look
i want you to guess who you think the
top five richest people in america are
top five versus people yup don't look um
jeff bezos yes uh
warren buffett no no he's probably six
or seven
um elon is six or seven uh
jeff bezos i mean warren buffett is in
the top five but he's not
number two oh no no but he's in top five
okay okay
okay okay okay okay bezos stop looking
mark zuckerberg oh you're so annoying
all right who else is in there don't
look
i i can name like in the table how did
you miss bill gates oh bill gates bill
gates mark zuckerberg
warren buffett and larry ellison okay
but the other ones include like
uh the waltons all three waltons are in
the top 15
probably right yep alice walton alice
alice jim and rob
i want you to guess i want to guess the
top three women
in mackenzie bezos yes no but she's not
the first
i know but she's definitely the top
three she's the second richest woman in
america who's the
top richest woman uh looking up there
there's only three p there's only three
women that i i know of being
up there uh one of them has to be oprah
or clothes no
she's not in the top three no not even
close
okay um alice walton she's number one
alice walton is the only daughter of
forbes 400
i'm sorry of walmart founder of san juan
samuel yeah so alice walton mackenzie
bezos
um and i'm gonna go with other other
people that are up there
is uh laureen powell jobs up there she
is up here
what number is she 30 30. but like in
the women
one two three four five uh and then
probably the coke sister the coke sister
julia
what is she and family she's 45 billion
oh she's number three
so it goes alice walter and she's scott
julia coke
and then all these mars people so
jacqueline mars but then look at this
marie gay mars yeah valerie victoria
yeah um that's how well i mean abigail
johnson yeah she's the philadelphia ceo
yeah but look at this so so
okay so ready alice walton is the
richest woman in america she's worth
62.3
i don't think that this is true still
okay wait why i think mackenzie bezos is
now the richest woman oh
the date the date is already out of uh
and then
62.3 billion uh forbes your thing
doesn't work
and then jeff bezos is 179 billion yeah
jeff bezos has over 200 billion anyway
uh
and and jeff bezos has 200 billion
dollars and he gave his wife enough
money to be number two
the second most richest i actually think
that right now
based on current stock prices jeff bezos
is the richest man in the world and
mackenzie bezos is the richest woman in
the world
which means that literally when jeff
bezos and her got divorced he gave her
the divorce settlement
and that made her the richest woman in
the world and he still
is the richest man involved you know
that's how much money you know what i
want to be what this is going to be a
very pimp thing to say
what not pauline about pimp what i want
to be the richest woman in the world
not from family inheritance or marriage
good candy can is dinner on you tonight
dinner's on me baby okay ready i'm gonna
order like a
like a hog i'm gonna order so much food
okay i'm not there yet
oh all right what's going on with the
kardashians
kardashians after 20 seasons i think
that's 14 years yeah
hundreds of episodes and several
spin-off shows they've decided as a
family to end
this is a very beautiful do you know why
it ended do you want to know why it
ended
last night planet tweeted this and i was
like oh damn chris
chloe right that's one of the names kim
rob like i know some of the names
but i spelled chris c-h-r-i-s like
chris's spell
who is that and she was like no it's
k-r-i-s that's why the show got
cancelled
it's spelled with a k not c h or i
they're all spelled with a k
chris kim kylie yeah but kylie and kim
are spelled with case chris is not
spelled with a k who made that up
kendall what's her real name chloe is
spelled with a ch
no no it's spelled k-h-l-o-e right well
chris is her real name
i just like the rob guy and the scott uh
what's the guy's name
scott scott disick that one right there
yeah i like those guys you like scott
disick no you want to know why people
like skype you want to know why i like
both those guys
because they got a hard life dealing
with all that
okay rob does not deal with all that
exactly that he's just he's out that's
the blac chyna guy
yeah see i know i pay attention i read
the internet
imagine being a boy in that whole family
that's what i'm saying that's why
i feel for them can you imagine on a
daily basis
not only having to deal with your
sisters or your cousins or whatever all
the things are
but then you got a camera in your face i
just realized kanye also starts with the
k that's wild
do we think this anything like this has
anything to do is kanye richer than
all no i think he is i don't believe so
i think so we i think kanye's worth two
billion dollars no he's not
didn't he just become a billionaire
kylie's been there forever
no i think i think kanye i think yeezy
is worth
no i think it's actually 3.2 billion
dollars look it up what's easy valuation
this is what happens when you read the
internet go ahead oh
around 3 billion that's easy that's not
him he owns a hundred percent easy
i don't know got real quiet in here see
what happens
see what happens also for those of you
who noticed
all right tell your jokes so we can get
out okay but the kardashians aren't you
sad
no i don't care that literally that's
the dumbest thing okay
my father like it's like being famous
you cannot interrupt the joke no i can
interrupt the jokes i just want to make
one thing clear just so
everyone remembers what happened the
reason why they're famous is because the
daughter did a sex tape
no it's because the mom took advantage
of that moment okay
freddie my friend the daughter still did
it my father quietly retired from his
job as an
eyeglass manufacturer because he
couldn't see anymore
he didn't want to make a spectacle
okay time to go all right guys that's it
for lunch monday today
hope you guys have a great day while
while she's trying to get rich for us
let's just trying to get our lunch money
right we'll see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click
on i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends